I think what people need to realize is
that you know for your own health and
for protecting our community at large
it's important for us to take care of
our health because one we know that
sugar and starch and processed food are
immune suppressive that they're going to
actually make your body less able to
fight the coronavirus so for your own
self-interest the important thing is to
eat a lot of protective foods that are
gonna boost immunity they're gonna make
you more resilient less likely to get
sick and to not eat all the stuff that
you think is comfort food but it's
actually going to make you more sick and
it's also you know important for for the
bigger problem which is the burden on
the health care system because if more
of us don't take care of ourselves more
of us suppress our immunity by not doing
the things we need to do for self care
and food in particular we're gonna get
sick we're gonna go to the healthcare
system we're gonna burden the hospitals
it is gonna be worse so I think there's
an argument to be made both you know for
your own health and as well as a social
conscience to actually focus on taking
care of your own health and I think
there are a lot of ways to eat delicious
comfort food so for example I made the
other night like pasta right but I used
chickpea pasta which is high in protein
there's no gluten and I made this
incredible you know Puttanesca which was
very cheap very cheap is like it was
called the horse pasta from Naples which
is a said you know anchovies and capers
and olives and tomatoes and olive oil
and garlic and onions and it's
incredibly warm and comforting and you
can make delicious food I'm eating
chicken soup which is again lasted us
for four days or the one chicken and
tons of root vegetables so it doesn't
have to be expensive and it doesn't have
to even take that long but I think I
think now's the time when we have time
at home when we can get still fresh food
when we actually can cook a little bit
because if people start using this time
at home that they were commuting or
driving to work or people are off work
starting self-care is going to make you
happier you less depressed you feel
better and also making much less likely
you're gonna get sick or if you get sick
or gonna be able to fight it off
and my outlook on this is you know you
can't be great without a fight
right so this is the fight that's gonna
make me great then I'm gonna look
forward I'm gonna embrace it and I'm
gonna win and I'm only gonna have a
positive outlook on it and every time I
hear about something that's happened to
somebody else I feel for them but it
just makes me tighten up it makes me get
stronger you know what I mean why do I
worry about is the people that I can't
control you know the people that I love
that it's still going everything they
want to do and they gotta learn they own
way but the thing about loving people is
when they hurt you hurt you know I'm
saying like the crazy thing is I ain't
been on my block daily living like 25
years but every time somebody goes to
jail
there was somebody sound somebody gets
killed or dies you feel it just like you
did you know you never really fun if
you're really from this so there's
people you worried about like the only
way I could really be hurt because I got
gonna take any kind of painting I'm with
it but when I when people I love or her
that's what really hurts you know and
that's where the Karma kicks in so my
worry ain't about me it'd be for
everybody I love you know I'm saying it
but I'm no longer waiting period or at
least or at least I'm gonna do
everything I've gotta do to win so let's
say I don't I know I gave 100 if I get
100 to me I want anyway you can
understand period it there is no loss
when you go we are the papers
oh no it is no loss when you give 100
you know I'm saying there is no loss and
if you keep calling while everybody else
is bugging up then you will be able to
pick up some because you know the masses
go crazy and we're meant to be
controlled you know the only way to
control the masses is if you got
everybody thinking one
exact same thing everybody gotta be
thinking the same thing
they gotta be listening to the same room
and they all got to be scared of the
same and then that's the way you get
controlled you know I'm saying so you
know even though there's some things and
guidelines that we have to abide by and
be conscious of I'm not gonna be scared
that's the one thing I'm not gonna do is
feel fear I'm gonna know that I need to
be conscious it's like when I cross the
street
I'm not scared across the street I know
there's a car that could hit me but I
know to wait for the stop sign and I
know it'll you know I know how to stop
when it's coming or if I got a run but
I'm not gonna be a victim you know I
mean I know I'm not doing that that's
what I'm not gonna do you know but this
is really these people that be like yo I
don't care if I got Corolla and they
want everybody else to feel bad cuz they
feel bad and that's how a lot of this
time that's how a lot of people are just
because they suck they want to stuff if
they got dealt a bad hand they feel like
everybody else deserves a bad hand and
that's the test you know when you get a
bad hand I supposed to look at like I
want everybody to feel my pain you
supposed to look at it like I'm going
through pain so no one knows has to go
through the pain and that's the really
the way I see them you guys got to
figure something out that that's
different that's needed and so we did
you know we we figured out this what can
we make that because not everybody has a
sewing machine at home not everybody
knows how to sew and but everybody has a
pair of scissors at home right and
everybody has some type of materials
whether it's a coffee filter or vacuum
bags or t-shirts like everybody has that
and there's different levels of
filtration so we came up with this thing
the death mask the defense mask for that
bro this thing went Richter this week
we're where we made 12,000 I mean going
from design to retooling Monday morning
like 40 45 minutes move machine around
and start making so or you travel what
what's the order numbers look like right
now
we're well over 16,000 are probably
creeping on 20,000 orders that's cool
cuz I've got probably another I would
say four to six thousand of people that
have hit me up and I know I set you one
individual today that if there's gonna
be some it's gonna be some does those
numbers just gonna continue to climb
yeah and and just so people know yes
we're also donating a lot of masks so
we're making a lot of masks were we've
got we put out a request form and we
received seven thousand requests for
donations so we Mun Monday we made set
like Monday morning that the team didn't
even know what's happening I came and I
was like here it is I put on the table I
said we need this in this I said I don't
know what we have in storage but I know
we have on the floor we need to shut
down the ghee line the ghee line just
completely shut down making peas and Yi
pants Joe and Bill they went over they
went became the storage facility we we
moved a bunch of machines around
retooled built out the workflow
everybody started sat down and started
working first day we did 780 second day
we did 990 then it was like three
thousand you know 3,100 3,200 and we
just started cranky bro it's like it's
Matt it's absolute madness and but it's
but it's awesome when you're cocooning
and you want to come out as a butterfly
because we feel like we're in a cocoon
along with our thoughts and our fears
and our doubts use this for clarity for
your life
there it is power use this you know
you for us a time to to care for
yourself really care for your immune
system
you know vitamins vitamin C vitamin D
all the antioxidants threesome saying
Care Mental Hygiene also not just rush
to your hands but washing your mind in a
form of brainwashing if you will is
because chronic fear compromises your
immune system it's an area called psych
psycho neuro human ology where chronic
stress and fear and anxiety suppresses
your immune system makes you more
susceptible to colds and flus and
viruses so make sure you care for
yourself make sure you're getting sleep
sleep is so important for your immune
system and prioritize asleep but before
we begin once again remember stay home
stay safe wash your hands regularly
sanitize your hands use masks wherever
required practice social distancing and
keep yourself safe and healthy keep your
family safe and healthy and keep
everybody else around you safe and
healthy as well I have this problem with
overthinking and how can one overcome
this problem of overthinking I think
what happens with a lot of passes we get
conditioned to live our lives in certain
ways it becomes a part of us it becomes
a habit we become conditioned to it and
it's very difficult to come out of that
particular habit it's very difficult to
come out of that conditioning in this
particular case the example being
overthinking and therefore if we are
meant to come out of any habit here or
thinking we have to start our process of
practicing how to get out of it in a
microwave for a micro macro
transformation over a large
transformation but how in particular
would we deal with this habit of
overthinking a the first thing that
comes to my mind is usually we are
thinking a lot when we do not have
enough to not to say Jacob that you
don't have enough to do but when we are
not occupied with things outside then we
are a lot
okyou pide with the mind
inside which is why when we are wanting
to overcome the habit of overthinking it
is important that we also have
occupation we occupy ourselves outside
we take up something to learn we take up
the we take up the process of making
deeper relationships or conversing with
people communicating with people we take
up something in a way that our mind is
not going to go into the loop of
overthinking so yes the first thing that
we could do is occupy ourselves with
things outside whatever it could be for
you and you will see that the benefit of
it would be that the process of
overthinking inside will slowly kind of
start reducing because now the mind is
focused on something outside so if
you're not focusing on something outside
and doing something constructive and
doing something meaningful in doing
something valuable then the mind is
constantly going into mind is going to
constantly go into the loop of
overthinking so I think that's something
that we could definitely try if you want
more advice wisdom guidance from other
successful entrepreneurs on how you can
navigate the coronavirus situation check
out the video right there next to me I
hope you find it valuable continue to
believe and I'll see you there well it's
similar in some respects that is a
respiratory illness